Oi boa tarde estou muito feliz de voltar
na Fapi em uma das minhas faculdades Eu
sou Chris quer e hoje a gente vai falar
sobre temas extremamente importantes
vieses inconscientes diversidade
inclusão vocês sabiam que todas as
pessoas têm viagens inconscientes eu
descobri que eu tinha vieses
inconscientes quando eu li um livro de
uma professora de Harvard chamada banagi
o livro dela se chama Blind Spot viés de
ponto cego Foi aí que eu descobri os
meus vieses e fui estudar um pouco mais
sobre esse tema e entender como que ele
impactava a diversidade EA inclusão
ah e hoje eu vou trazer para vocês
algumas informações super importantes
como entender então o que que é
diversidade diversidade é a
multiplicidade é a variedade Isso quer
dizer então que todas as pessoas são
diversas só que o nosso cérebro adora
categorizar tudo e todos não existe
ninguém igual a ninguém a gente tem que
olhar as pessoas de forma individual
vamos pegar um exemplo um casal de
irmãos gêmeos eles podem ser idênticos
nas suas características físicas mas
quando nós olhamos a diversidade
cognitiva que são os pensamentos as
ideias e os talentos Eles são muito
diferentes então é como a nossa digital
não tem ninguém igual a nossa digital só
que para gente então é muito difícil
olhar dessa forma e por que que hoje
e empresas a gente ouvi falar muito
sobre os grupos minorizados que eles são
formados por mulheres pessoas negras
pessoas dos grupos LGBT e mais pessoas
com deficiência porque esses são os
grupos com menor representatividade
dentro das corporações por isso que a
gente tem esse olhar Além disso quando a
gente olha esse grupo Na nossa população
hoje a gente tem uma grande população de
pessoas negras que é formada por pessoas
pretas e pardas quase 56 por cento da
nossa população quando a gente olha
mulheres a gente tem 51,8 por cento de
mulheres na nossa população e pessoas
com deficiência 23,9 ou seja onde estão
essas pessoas quando a gente olha nas
instituições e nas empresas elas não
estão nem nos cargos de alta liderança
nem nos cargos de
Oi e a gente vai entender um pouquinho O
porquê disso tudo que está envolvido com
os nossos vieses inconscientes quando a
gente olha inclusão inclusão nosso
cérebro é um cérebro muito associativo
ele adora fazer associações e como a
gente ouviu a palavra inclusão muitas
vezes relacionada a pessoas com
deficiência inclusão social a gente
guardas informação dentro do nosso
cérebro mas na verdade inclusão a gente
está falando de todas as pessoas Todo
mundo precisa se sentir incluído a gente
começa olhando o que o senso de
pertencimento todas as pessoas precisam
se sentir pertencentes precisa se sentir
parte depois valorização puxa eu entro
no projeto eu quero participar do
projeto importante eu tô numa reunião eu
quero que escutem o que eu estou falando
então inclusão envolve todos esses
pontos e mais um fundamental que é o
respeita
e como é que eu posso estar numa reunião
Ou em qualquer ambiente houve por
exemplo uma piada uma brincadeira isso
fere diretamente a pessoa quando nós
estamos nos ambientes nós precisamos de
segurança psicológica para a gente ter
produtividade é assim que nosso cérebro
funciona ele está sempre buscando eu
estou sobre ameaça ou estou no lugar
seguro É isso que o nosso cérebro faz o
tempo inteiro isso está relacionado com
inclusão e com a produtividade das
pessoas existe uma frase muito famosa da
velha Meyer que é vice-presidente de de
inclusão estratégica na Netflix que fala
diversidade ou convida para o baile
inclusão eu convido para dançar como é
que a gente traz isso para nossa
realidade diversidade o que tá
acontecendo a gente traz as pessoas para
dentro dos ambientes corporativos Mas
será que efetivamente elas estão se
sentindo incluídas
bom então se sentindo bem nesse ambiente
como é que a gente caminha então para
inclusão como entender um pouquinho
primeiro. A exclusão pessoa que não tem
viessem consciente nenhum aqui são
pessoas que falam assim não quero
mulheres no meu time não quero pessoas
com deficiência não quero pessoas negras
Isto é exclusão não tem viés
inconsciente nenhum aqui depois a gente
vai para integração que é exatamente o
que está acontecendo nos ambientes
corporativos eu trago as pessoas
diversas Mas eu não estou fazendo ela se
sentir em incluídas ainda a gente tem
uma tendência a gente busca pessoas
muito parecidas conosco então quando eu
entro numa empresa e eu sinto que não
tem representatividade minha ali eu vou
procurar as pessoas que são iguais a mim
essa ela fazer para quando a gente vai
no evento quando a gente chega no evento
a primeira coisa que a gente faz a gente
dá uma olhada para ver se a gente
conhece alguém naquele ambiente para que
eu me senti
E é isso que a gente busca o tempo
inteiro essa segurança eu encontro com
os iguais então quando a gente olha nas
empresas a gente tem os grupos juntos
pessoas com deficiência pessoas negras
homens mulheres a gente precisa com
conseguir ficar perto de outras pessoas
que é exatamente a inclusão é quando
estamos todos juntos e misturados
sentindo que eu sou naquele em qualquer
ambiente que eu estiver eu estou me
sentindo valorizada eu estou me sentindo
respeitada naquele ambiente Qual que é o
grande desafio da história toda a gente
tem um cérebro e dentro desse cérebro a
gente tem um dos sistemas que se chama
inconsciente esse nosso sistema
inconsciente é um sistema aqui também é
conhecido como automático emocional e
instintivo e sistema nosso sistema
primitivo a nosso sistema de
sobrevivência que a gente tinha lá atrás
hoje eu precisava ver
e na minha frente entender que aquele
animal poderia me matar então eu criava
uma associação esse animal vai me matar
eu tenho que me preparar Então esse
sistema ele é um sistema que ele cria
várias associações mentais ele guarda
todas essas informações esse sistema
grande função dele é reconhecer padrões
e criar memória emocional então o que
que esse sistema faz é como se dentro
dele a gente tivesse uma mochila e essa
mochilinha a gente vai guardando todas
as experiências que a gente teve a nossa
vida inteira eu vou guardando ali
positiva ou negativa se informação e aí
na hora que eu encontro com uma pessoa o
meu cérebro tem um gatilho mental e
buscas informação dentro dessa mochila e
me traz Qual é a informação que está
gravada Então vamos dizer que eu
encontro uma pessoa que me lembra alguém
com que eu tive uma experiência
profissional ruim ou eu acho
o meu ontem e essa pessoa que estava ali
era a pessoa do Mal encontro hoje com
uma pessoa que lembra ela o que que
acontece com meu cérebro ele traz essa
referência então é mais ou menos aquela
intuição que a gente tem quando a gente
chega no espaço fala assim não gostei
dessa pessoa ou a gente fala assim
adorei essa pessoa não sei o quê que foi
são essas informações que o seu cérebro
está trazendo para você ele faz esse
gatilho mental e faz uma comparação e
traz a informação para você e aquilo que
você vivenciou ele trazer exatamente a
mesma experiência
e ele traz também dentro desse sistema
inconsciente ele vai armazenando ali
todos os estereótipos que a gente vai
adquirindo durante a nossa vida toda o
que que são os estereótipos são
categorizações que a gente vai criando
para pessoas e para grupos sociais então
eu moro uma pessoa eu vejo ela e já
trago as informação de qual estereótipo
eu tenho guardado a gente também ao
longo da vida vai recebendo da nossa
família todas as crenças então aquilo
tudo que a gente acredita como uma
verdade que muitas vezes foi passado por
um avô por uma avó por um pai por um tio
para uma mãe por um professor e a gente
guarda essas informações que viram
verdades absolutas E essas esses
estereótipos essas crianças levam a
gente a ter os preconceitos o que que é
o preconceito é um julgamento sempre
hostil e negativo referente alguma
pessoa criado por conta do estereótipo
e das crenças a gente também tem
influência das crenças culturais a gente
tá num país que é um país que tem uma
cultura ainda muito machista muito
racista muito homofóbica muito capacetes
tá muito classista então todas essas
influências Estão guardadas aqui dentro
do nosso cérebro vamos entender melhor
quando eu falo para vocês assim pensa na
pessoa que comanda o avião Será que a
primeira informação que veio para vocês
foi essa aqui
é ou será que a informação que veio para
vocês foi essa aqui porque quando a
gente pensa primeiro a palavra comanda
será que quando a gente pensa em
comandar a gente pensa num homem a gente
pensa numa mulher quando a gente pensa
na palavra Líder Será que eu penso em um
homem ou eu penso em uma mulher
liderando então isso está armazenado
aqui dentro do seu cérebro Esses são os
estereótipos qual é o lugar que eu
acredito de cada pessoa a gente pode
olhar a mulher e como a gente viu poucas
comandantes como ela e mais comandantes
como ele a gente guarda exatamente essa
informação no nosso cérebro
e essa mulher quando a gente olha para
ela qual é a primeira informação que o
seu cérebro te manda Qual é o cargo que
você acredita que essa mulher tem
Normalmente quando eu faço esse
exercício as pessoas me dizem Ah eu acho
que ela trabalha numa ONG ou então as
pessoas me falam o seguinte Olha na
verdade eu acho que ela é uma professora
ou eu acho que ela é uma enfermeira mas
muito mas muito dificilmente as pessoas
vão me dizer que ela pessoa que tem o
cargo mais alto na empresa na verdade
essa aqui é a Ursula burns ela foi
presidente esse ou da Xerox Mas por que
que a gente não guarda essa Associação
com quantas pessoas negras você estudou
na sua vida com quantas pessoas negras
Você fez faculdade na vida com quantas
pessoas negras você trabalhou que eram
os gerentes diretores e diretoras de
empresa então a gente guarda Exatamente
Essa associação no nosso
a hora que eu encontro a Úrsula eu tenho
uma dificuldade de trazer essa
informação de entender que a Úrsula é a
pessoa que ocupa a posição mais alta
dentro da Corporação vamos mais um
exemplo quando eu olho esse homem Qual a
informação que eu tenho sempre nós temos
associações positivas para pessoas
tatuadas hoje temos Inúmeras pessoas
tatuadas mas muitas vezes quando eu
pergunto para as pessoas como foi quando
você fez tatuagem a pessoa fala A minha
mãe falou que não ia arrumar emprego a
minha mãe falou que não ia dar certo o
pai também então quanto a gente ainda
atrás de associações negativas ou uma
tatuagem E aí quando a gente olha ele
sempre que a gente associa ele é um
político ou será que a gente associa ele
a um chefe de cozinha é um roqueiro a um
motoqueiro a um tatuador que são
normalmente a as o que vem as pessoas me
contam que elas acham do John
o seu Johnny ele é Vice governador da
Pensilvânia nos Estados Unidos ele faz
um trabalho maravilhoso com jovens
carentes tirando eles da vida e trazendo
eles de volta para estudar agora porque
a gente não consegue fazer essa
Associação porque a gente não guarda
essa Associação quando eu vejo John ele
me lembra nunca vai me lembrar um
político ele vai me lembrar de ver essas
outras outros cargos e outras funções
vou contar um exemplo pessoal que
aconteceu na minha vida porque os vieses
inconscientes eles estão baseados muito
na sua experiência pessoal eu sou de São
Paulo a família do meu pai de Taubaté
aqui pertinho E todas as vezes que a
gente estava na estrada meu pai quando
eu era pequena ele Virava para mim
falava assim cuidado com esses
motoqueiros cuidado com esses grupos de
motoqueiros é o que que eu queria eu
queria uma crença de que esse grupo não
era um grupo muito legal que que
acontece uma vez eu sofri um acidente de
carro na estrada
a e foi socorrida por esse grupo de
motoqueiros que ajudou todas as pessoas
que sofreram acidentes e foi assim que
eu desconstruir uma crença que meu pai
tinha passado para mim sem ele nem saber
que ele tinha me passado essa crença
bom então pessoal o que acontece é que
esse nosso cérebro ele vai armazenando a
nossa vida inteirinha todos os
estereótipos aquilo que eu vi os
preconceitos que eu fui adquirindo e as
nossas crenças quando a gente fala por
exemplo de pessoas negras né as pessoas
têm tem uma tendência dizer não Cristina
eu na verdade eu não sou racista eu falo
então vamos fazer um teste para ver se
você é racista ou não porque porque
muitos desses desses estereótipos que a
gente vai guardando dessas crenças que a
gente vai guardando a gente não sabe que
a gente tem elas estão no lado
inconsciente do meu cérebro eu preciso
trazer ele para o consciente do cérebro
quando a gente vai por exemplo a
linguagem que a gente usa a lista negra
o mercado negro a inveja branca porque
ela é positiva A Ovelha Negra Então tudo
isso vai formando esses estereótipos
dentro da nossa mente e é por isso que a
gente precisa então
a mente o que a professora mahzarin
banaji conta pra gente Nós preferimos
acreditar que somos pessoas sem
preconceitos mas as Pesquisas mostram o
contrário Esta é uma constatação
desconfortável é Muito desconfortável a
gente se perceber estereotipando as
pessoas a gente se perceber tem um
preconceito a gente perceber que a gente
tem uma crença mas ter um viés não é o
fim do mundo a única vergonha é se você
não fizer nenhum esforço para melhorar
então meu convite para cada um e para
cada uma de vocês é Pensa aí o que que
tem guardado dentro da sua mente ampliar
sua consciência da gente entender Será
que eu tenho vi assim consciente sim
você tem viagem consciente O Grande
Desafio aqui é você ampliar sua
consciência entender Quais são os seus
porque só assim você vai conseguir mudar
e eu gosto de terminar sempre com uma
frase que é pequenas mudanças fazem uma
grande
e a gente não vai conseguir mudar tudo
de hoje para amanhã mas o meu convite é
para que cada um e cada uma pense de
forma consciente para que a gente
consiga então trazer essa consciência e
fazer uma transformação muito obrigada a